hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to binding of issac
afterbirth now this DLC was released on
Halloween of this year and I've actually
played this game before rebirth but not
the DLC and when I played it before
apparently I did something so incredible
and got these special items that
conjoined with this other item that I
was supposed to get and I did something
amazing in my run and no one could
believe that I got so lucky on my first
try
but I bet I'll never be able to repeat
that again so I'm gonna play it again
and I have no idea what's gonna happen
so I also don't know what's new in the
afterbirth DLC I'm just assuming that
it's gonna lead to a lot of uh a lot of
uh new thing right whoa hey whoa whoa
whoa I don't know what that was all
about see I don't know what's gonna be
new and I don't know what's gonna be old
in this game because I've never actually
really played the game before so it's
kind of just gonna be random chance as
to what I can see but most of you
already know about games you want to see
me play the other stuff just watch it
there's a link in the description the
leads to a playlist where I played a
whole bunch of things this guy oh that's
right oh did I mention I I attack by
crying that's kind of an important
detail in this whole game may not get
you stupid a-hole okay nevermind then I
guess he's just gonna be but I need to
kill him I think he I need to kill him I
need to kill him to clear the room and
then be able to progress there we go god
damn it okay so now that we did that
unorthodox way now we can actually do a
thing no we can't cuz we have no bombs
oh hell oh yeah don't cry me
yeah good god I kind of forgot how
bulbous and horrifying some of these
creatures are and also the things that
they drop when they die piles of meat Oh
God
no wonder you're crying get flies in
your brain Oh most of this game is based
on blood and thunder and horrible things
such as that more like lemon fecal
matter damn it
I gotta be more oh crap oh I didn't mean
to go into the boss room I didn't find
anything oh crap well I guess we're
playing now uh it's binding of issac
hard mode by the way death is permanent
and whatnot and also I'm not very good
at the game even though I did pretty
good last one I had a fun
I know dang it never mind everything I
said is totally wrong I had a pretty
impressive performance in the last time
just because I had I think I had to go
through the the final boss with only one
life and I was very very close to not
making it through and also for some
reason death wasn't permanent
I don't remember what happened it's been
a long time whoa oh no I fir I thought
those dear diary today I died I was
killed by this thing in some basement I
leave all that I own to my cat guppy
goodbye cruel world okay thank you
alright so anyway let's try this again
I'm not gonna suck ass like I did last
time oh good I do that's right I didn't
even get to think of the thing there was
a golden door and I didn't even go
through it people are probably still
pissed at me because there's a lot of
people that are really into this game
and definitely uh definitely look down
upon those that aren't as good at this
game as others such as the me but you
guys will see that I'm actually gonna be
very good because I know my things I
shouldn't have gone in here because I
don't have any money
hahaha there was no point in me wasting
a key on this door okay alright I'm
doing real good so happy but those
little turds that are floating around
why am I in a land full of turds and
magic and purple tears and this is what
I do this is what I do with my mystical
powers I make my tears go in homing shot
oh well whatever poop everywhere alright
this time it's gonna go a little better
ow
nevermind god damn it why do I gotta
suck I get hit by the smallest enemies
it's been a while just let me be I'm not
playing with a controller I think a
controllers probably way better this
game yeah I kind of my main problem is
that I forgot about the dynamics of how
the whoo you're different
I've never played whoa hey watch out
horsey
whoa hey hey what are you doing there
you being cute
you better not be cute whoa so can he
only go horizontally ah
okay well that that makes it interesting
because if you can only go horizontally
than that means Evo oh god oh god oh god
get away get away get away do bad touch
bad touch bad touch yeah damn those
flies wouldn't stay off in the distance
like that I might be able to actually do
something with my life oh god he killed
his own dude okay so there's a little
bit to strategy to this guy he'll yell
uh-oh Oh God
things have changed really quickly yeah
I forgot how far these shots go whoa Dom
god dammit [ __ ]
nope it's a different control scheme
than what I'm used to so it's kind of
little kind of messing with me a bit Oh
God so close I'm so bad haha okay this
time forget about everything you just
saw a montage of my failures and now
it's actually gonna get serious because
now I met at the game now I'm gonna be
so pro you guys gonna see it's gonna be
awesome
look at me go I'm so good at this Oh
Frick yeah why is it these guys not
dying that quicker place I need it I
need to excavate the giant piles of poop
so that I can get the things that I need
to get and then you all need to die
little blood bag douche nozzles ok so
then now that I'm actually buh dick now
that I'm actually playing the game for
real I was about to say we can actually
get down to the heart of the matter
I'm a heart of the matter this game is
fun because it's totally randomly
generated and there's almost unlimited
replayability potential which is why
there's some people with miniseries many
episodes in the series of this game and
that's why it's kind of fun to watch I
don't want to go through that door
because gonna hurt roid rage speed and
range up I don't know oh oh that's my
face okay I don't know what me putting a
coin into that thing did Oh dill yeah
but didn't do I don't know what this
pill do how oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay alright I don't remember what this
guy supposed to do is does he give me an
extra heart oh god oh oh he asked for a
heart Jesus then this is the worst of
all scenarios cuz his door hurts and I'm
not gonna be able to make it through
anything now oh god you guys are gonna
see a big montage of failure if I can't
get through this one with only one hit
left which is what I'm gonna have to do
and I'm gonna be a badass about and I'm
not gonna complain [ __ ] because I if
there's one thing Markab all right he
ain't no puss so I'm gonna get this
straight up yo
hot diggety to the d-o-double-g I don't
know there we go
god damn heart okay so down there's a
locked door let's see what through the
door oh it's another shop God you look
scary oh you're so scary okay I can't do
anything there those wastes of key boom
Dabba Dabba to all the pro players are
mad at me
Oh God hey big guys are you doing
buddies you're looking good today with
your far clouds looking real nice don't
mind me while I go get this heart oh I
just backed myself into a corner didn't
there you can't get inside also you guys
were on fire how do I get out well I
know how to get out fill that down whoa
whoa your face oh god your melty faces
no no no no no no no no no day away stay
away stay away hey dodge epic dodge jeez
you're so creepy and weird uh why do
they got to be so weird hey buddy how
are you doing you don't look like you're
doing so good the other guy had flies in
his face and you got spiders all over
your face all inside your face actually
I'm guessing so what are the other
monsters in this area because there's a
lot like I've never actually read up on
like the story behind binding of issac
the five petrified poop it feels lucky
why does it feel lucky yeah oh god I
gotta get okay I don't kill it kill it
kill it we can I hit it just hit the
damn thing there's a damn dang it what
does it do job god ah come on
oh you son of a [ __ ] just hit that damn
bag huh stupid it's stupid this stupid I
gotta face the boss with half a heart oh
good a whole heart thank you thanks
Larry jr. I'm gonna be fine on this one
I got this one
Oh maybe I don't oh boy
okay yeah okay I got this dang with the
poop yeah yeah yeah oh god oh yes oh
girl yes oh yes okay okay okay we're
fine it's not that easy why do I keep
hitting only the rocks and nothing else
I would love it I was actually able to
hit something I wanted to hit oh they
have butt cracks too
I didn't know the Larry jr. had butt
cracks come on Larry jr.
what you got nothing that's right mr.
butt crack
whoa how you doing oh that's why you're
laying out poop everywhere one that's
really gross but come on a little bit of
hygiene never hurt anybody
oh you got to be so gross freakin
weirdos I don't know what this AI is all
about but it's a little bizarre I almost
got it though oh look at me look at me
look at me look at me look at me okay
speed and damage up nothing like a
little child taking growth hormones to
pump up everything good thing I got
spots all over my brain I hope those
aren't spiders growing up hey candy oh
there's a razor blade in it yeah yeah
yeah arkaid ha ha I want to go in the
arcade bro oh not what I wanted not what
I wanted all right thanks thank you
there we go
boom I don't know what this do but I got
another weird growth of my Chi
I've got testicle Chin's I don't know
what the pills do I forget oh oh
pheromones I don't want to know what
that means
I don't know that means Oh tea and tea
probably ain't a good thing it seems to
be a lot of boob does that my only
opportunity to make this thing blow up
properly that was probably my only
opportunity wasn't it I really try this
Oh Oh God
well Anna wasn't the worst thing in the
world all right okay still alive barely
uh God flys flys flys flys well I flies
why weird flies weird flies weird twice
we're okay we're okay we're okay we're
okay okay we're fine we're fine okay so
now that we're moving along see the
point of this game is to get to the end
of the dungeons and then you can replay
the game over and over again because
there's a lot of stuff available
padushka ha buhdeuce key I got a monster
manual temporary buddy bender temporary
buddy buddy generator what's that dude I
don't know what that new oh I didn't
mean to do that anyway well got him on a
diamond a diamond a dime a dime a dime a
dime a dime
Hey gonna die gonna die maybe I won't
die why is that guy begging Bluegreen
who you're a crying baby who do you're
gonna be crying to this with your
explosions in your face you dead yet
you're dead you're dead yet okay I'll
take that and I'll take this and I'll go
through this door oh I don't think I
want any of this I like your face Lyle
your weird ass face god you're so weird
I could use some health oh I would love
some payoff oh god no no no now I'm a
fish well now my weird bulbous face
which probably has spiders and or
insects floating through them
no okay
what button did I used to use a bomb pop
II that was nothing it was a big waste
of everything hey [ __ ] whoa wait
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa I
don't know how to use my monster manual
that's the thing I don't know whoa Jesus
come on every
okay there was no point in coming down
here unless there's something in the
poop come on I want to harden the poop
give me the heart of the cards give me
the heart of the poop why is there pee
by the door why is there poo poo and pee
pee everywhere it's not a fun time here
okay maybe down here is there a mama
buleria nope
hi who is completely wrong hello spider
you're gonna kill me aren't you
Oh God oh yes oh yes ah poopy well as
you guys can see I'm very very bad at
this game but in the next episode I'm
gonna do much better don't you worry
about it I would be much more quality
than I was in this episode here though
thank you everybody so much for watching
I told you I couldn't repeat the
performance that I had in the last
series so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye I
know it's an old Olli function but a lot
of things in this world in normal bodily
functions that I've listed all night no
water come from the Hunger Games I was
thinking of